how are you buddy you're
adorable
son if I was gay I'd you for sure
you're the kind of guy always settle
down with you know what I mean I trust
you you have a trustworthy face what do
you do for a living
insurance I bet you do a dog you're the
safest bet in this hey you
know what else is Insurance you what's
your ethnicities I'm very confused by
this Dominican whoa light-skinned
Dominican I bet you're just swimming in
Dominican huh that's another
sociology less Anglo features a very
desirable and uh like minority
communities right like light skin I have
green eyes from my imperialism
he cares how it happened it's crazy I
used to ask my parents to be like hey
Mom Dad where did I get these green eyes
from and they'd be like
uh your great grandma talking for the
team okay that's happened